Tratemos de resolver una ecuación más elaborada. Digamos, la ecuación vamos a complicarla un poco.
"2x" más 3...
"2x" más 3 igual a "5x"... "5x" menos 2.
Esto parece desalentador,
tenemos "x" a ambos lados, números que
se suman y restan a ambos lados,
¿cómo le hacemos para resolver esto?
Lo vamos a hacer de dos maneras distintas,
pero lo importante, lo que tienes que tener
en mente es que se trata de despejar la "x",
una vez que llevas la ecuación a "x" igual a algo, ya has resuelto para "x" y puedes sustituir
en la ecuación original para verificar tu solución.
Lo que vamos a hacer son una serie de operaciones a ambos lados de la ecuación
para eventualmente despejar la "x".
A medida que vayamos haciéndolo vamos a visualizar
qué es lo que está sucediendo.
Para que no te preocupes de cuales son los
pasos o las reglas para resolver ecuaciones, entonces pienses que te faltó algo o que es lo que se puede
o que es lo que no se puede hacer,  sino que te des cuenta que es simplemente sentido común.
Entonces vamos a visualizar qué es lo
que está sucediendo.
Aquí tenemos "2x" es decir, "x" más "x",
a lo cual le estamos sumando 3, es decir,
más 1 más 1 más 1, eso sería más 3...
voy a ponerlo con bolitas o como fuera,
voy a indicarlo con el mismo color...
"2x" más 3 y esto es igual a "5x"... "5x"
que tenemos aquí...
que es "x" más "x" más "x" más "x" más "x".
Y que quede claro, no tenemos que hacer siempre esto para resolver ecuaciones, tenemos que
trabajar algebraicamente esta ecuación, lo que estoy haciendo aquí es simplemente visualizar
para que entendamos qué es lo que está sucediendo.
El lado izquierdo es estas "2x" naranjas más 3
y el lado derecho es "5x" menos 2 y menos
2 lo podemos escribir...
lo podemos escribir...
lo voy a hacer en un color distinto,
lo voy a hacer en rosa... menos 2 que podemos escribir como menos 1, menos 1.
Ahora, queremos llevar las "x" a un solo lado de la ecuación, ¿cómo puedo hacer esto?
Hay dos maneras de hacer esto, podemos restar
estas "2x" a ambos lados de la ecuación
y así el lado derecho tendríamos "5x" menos
"2x", un número positivo de "x"
o también podríamos restar "5x" a ambos lados de la
ecuación, eso es lo maravilloso del álgebra,
mientras hagas operaciones válidas, siempre
vas a obtener la misma respuesta.
Empecemos entonces restando "2x" a
ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿y qué quiere decir restar "2x"?
Pues vamos a eliminar "2x" del lado izquierdo
y para que no se altere nuestra ecuación,
necesitamos eliminar "2x" del lado derecho.
¿Qué nos resulta de esto?
Estamos restando "2x" del lado izquierdo
y también estamos restando "2x" del lado derecho.
¿Qué nos queda entonces del lado derecho?
Tenemos "2x" más 3 menos "2x", las "2x" se
cancelan y nos queda tan solo 3.
Aquí lo podemos ver, eliminamos "2x" y nos
quedan 1 más 1 más 1, del lado derecho teníamos,
"5x" y le restamos "2x" aquí lo vemos, restamos
"2x" a "5x" y nos queda "3x", nos quedan "3x"
menos 2, no le hicimos nada a estos -2.
Nos queda entonces del lado derecho "3x" menos 2.
Usualmente para resolver ecuaciones, solo hacemos esto que está escrito del lado izquierdo.
¿Qué hacemos ahora?
Recuerda que queremos despejar la "x", ya
llevamos las "x" del lado derecho,
así es que si nos deshacemos de este -2 que tenemos
aquí, estaríamos a un paso de lograrlo.
¿Entonces cómo podemos deshacernos de este -2?
Si lo vemos aquí es -1 -1, bien, podemos
sumar 2 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
observa lo que pasa, voy a agregar 2 del lado derecho,
lo voy a agregar como más 1 más 1, literalmente
he agregado 2 y lo voy a hacer también del lado izquierdo, 1 más 1 más, y he agregado 2 a ambos lados.
Vamos a hacerlo aquí también, sumamos 2 del lado izquierdo y sumamos 2 del lado derecho.
¿Qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo tenemos que 3 más 2 es
igual a 5 y del lado derecho nos queda,
"3x" menos 2 más 2, menos 2 más 2 se cancela
y nos queda tan solo "3x".
Vamos a ver qué pasó aquí.
Aquí tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho 1, 2, 3 "x" y -1 -1 más
1 más 1 se cancelan,
son estos términos -2 y más 2, la
ecuación ha quedado 5 igual a "3x".
Aquí lo tenemos, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 es igual a "3x".
Déjame borrar lo que ya hemos eliminado de
aquí, estas dos "x" ya están eliminadas...
aquí también, esto de aquí ya lo hemos
eliminado de la ecuación...
y esto de aquí vamos a borrar...
¡Perfecto! ya lo tenemos.
Así es que esto nos ha quedado, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
déjame mover esto, déjame pegarlo...
Vamos a cortar... y pegar...
Muy bien, aquí tenemos 5, estos dos son
estos 2 que sumamos aquí,
que es igual a "3x", estos 2 se cancelaron,
ya no aparecen ahí.
Ahora, para resolver esto simplemente dividimos
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 3
y esto va a ser un poco difícil de visualizar, pero
si dividimos aquí entre 3, ¿qué obtenemos?
Dividimos entre 3 del lado izquierdo y dividimos
entre 3 del lado derecho
y la razón por la cual dividimos entre 3 es porque la "x" está multiplicada por 3, 3 es el coeficiente de "x",
esa palabra extraña que significa el
número que multiplica a una variable.
Estos 3 se cancelan, así es que del lado derecho
nos queda, la "x" y del lado izquierdo
5/3...
5/3.
Hemos encontrado que "x" es igual a 5/3 y
esto es diferente a lo que habíamos visto
hasta ahora, la "x" está del lado derecho,
el 5/3 está del lado izquierdo, pero la solución
sigue siendo "x" igual a 5/3. Es lo mismo escribir 5/3 igual a "x",  que escribir "x" igual a 5/3,
estamos más acostumbrados a ésta pero son totalmente equivalentes,
ésta de aquí es exactamente lo mismo, si queremos escribir la solución como un número mixto,
bueno 5 entre 3 es igual a 1 y sobran
2, es decir, "x" es igual a 1 entero 2/3,
va a ser 1 entero 2/3.
La solución también la podemos escribir
como "x" igual a 1 entero 2/3 y te dejo de
tarea que sustituyas el valor de "x" en la
ecuación original y ver que efectivamente es correcto.
Ahora regresando a nuestra visualización,
¿cómo le hacemos para ver 1 entero 2/3?
Veamos esto, en vez de usar "unos"
voy a usar círculos...
no, pensándolo bien voy a usar cuadrados...
voy a tener 3 cuadrados del lado izquierdo,
los voy a hacer en amarillo...
1, 2, 3, 4, y 5 y eso es igual a "3x",
"x" más "x" más "x".
Ahora, estamos dividiendo ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 3...
estamos dividiendo ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 3, eso fue lo que hicimos aquí, dividir
ambos lados entre 3,
¿y eso cómo lo vemos aquí?
Bueno, el lado derecho es muy fácil, quieres
dividir estas tres "x" en tres grupos, 1,
2, 3, tres grupos. Ahora,
¿cómo podemos visualizar 5 entre 3?
Tenemos que formar grupos iguales y la
respuesta nos da la pista,
cada grupo va a tener 1 entero y 2/3, entonces aquí tenemos un grupo de 1 entero 2/3,
tomamos 2/3 del siguiente nos
queda 1/3 aquí...
nos queda aquí 1/3, le agregamos el siguiente
cuadro completamente, llevamos 1 entero 1/3,
hay que agregarlo 1/3 más del siguiente,
ya tenemos 1 entero 2/3
y ya quedaron los 3 grupos de 1 entero 2/3.
Aclaremos la visualización,
aquí tenemos un grupo...
este es 1 entero y aquí tenemos 2/3,
así es que aquí hay 1 entero 2/3, luego, aquí
tenemos 1/3, aquí tenemos otro tercio
y aquí tenemos 1 entero, aquí tenemos otro grupo
de 1 entero 2/3 y finalmente aquí tenemos 2/3
y aquí tenemos 1 entero, el último grupo
de 1 entero 2/3, así es que cuando dividimos
ambos lados entre 3, del lado izquierdo tenemos
tres secciones o tres paquetes de 1 entero 2/3,
equivalentes a 5/3 que estamos obteniendo del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho nos queda "x".
Y aunque es más difícil la visualización con fracciones, también funciona.